my name is stainless go I am the CEO and
president of the Danish company
Novozymes and I would like to answer the
question asked by atmosphere it over
YouTube the question is how can they be
sustainable growth when resource
depletion is imminent and that's exactly
what our company is trying to do to
available in all of them other good
companies trying to recover the growth
from resource utilization what we do in
our company in scale with our customers
is to make sure that they can produce
more from this in hood is creating less
waste using less energy than their
processes and in the opportunity to also
use renewable input rather than chemical
there's a lot of things going on right
now so I do think that we have an
opportunity to make that decoupling in a
significant way